(
culture
Google
I/O conference
STAGE 4
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
* * *
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of proceedings. This
text, document, or file is not
to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
* * *
>> Welcome.
Please fill in the seats near
the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Welcome.
Please fill in the seats near
the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
(Music)
>> CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Hi
there.  Thanks for joining us
today on a discussion on AR and
VR.  Today we want to provide
some background for those people
who aren't familiar and then
we'll share and principles and
guidelines and then finally
review with you different
disabilities and how to make
your
applications and experiences
more inclusive.  My name is
Christopher Patnoe.
I'm work here on Google's
central
disability team.
I've spent many, many years
working at Apple,
making games, even at Disney
mobile.
I've worked on Google Pay
music and even Daydream, our AR
and VR platform.  I've spent 20
plus years working in accessible
and for
the past year I've made
my passion my day job.
>> RAN TAO: Hi, I joined
daydream last year summer after
I
graduated from UC San Diego
where I studied computer
graphics
and computer vision.
I've been using a wheelchair
full-time now
for two years and I'm passionate
about promoting accessibility
and daydream
...
There's so many head sets out
there right now.
We've  partnered with Lenovo to
make the mirage solo.
These three  headsets have
distinctions.
The experience is kind of like a
movie projected on a sphere
around you.  And you're in the
center of that sphere so you can
look around but you can't really
lean in closer to any objects.
Then we have the mirage solo
with world sense which allows
for  six degrees of freedom
tracking.  That means not only
can you  look around but
forward, back, up, down, left,
right.
This  allows for a much more
natural
interaction where you can duck
when a snowball is thrown at
you.
My personal favorite is street
view.  Where I can go anywhere
in the world.
They even have 360 photos.  And
there's also  artistic apps like
Tiltbrush and experiences for
meditation,  training, and so
much more.
Let's move to AR where we can
bring things to you.
This  allows you to create these
experiences in Android, unity,
and  real engine.
You can also do fun things like
adding
sticker  like this storm trooper
here
Many people ask, what is
inclusive design?  To me, it
means  being mindful in your
choices so you don't exclude
someone  accidentally by a lack
of thought.  The way I got
involved here  in accessibility
is when I was on Google Play
music a tester  came up and
brought her device and a
speaker, plugged them in.   I
heard button, button, button.
I see people smile here because
you know what this means, but I
didn't at that time.  This means
the application was not
accessible.  So I asked, what is
this?   She said, well, this is
your application.  I said,
that's  stupid.  How does
someone use it?  She said,
that's why I'm  here.  It was at
that moment I realized it takes
zero effort to  make your
application not inclusive.  It
only takes a little bit  to make
it inclusive.
So that's what we're here to
talk about.  And accessibility
is one of the key lenses, one of
the most tangible lenses for
inclusive design.
And I think that's important to
remember is accessibility is  a
spectrum.
It's not a binary on/off thing.
Many common  ailments you may
not
recognize to having a
disability, like   arthritis or
even a bad back.
There is still lots of nuances
within these groupings of
disabilities.  It's more like
cups  inside of buckets.
Because as they're individual
people and  people have
different abilities and didn't
kinds of disabilities  and
they're very subtle.
Unfortunately you are
fortunately, the  things that
help those different groups
bring those both up  together
all the time.
You also want to think about
situational
and temporary  impairments like
a broken
leg or carrying a bag of
groceries,  and all these
situational impairments.
Finally, different people learn
at different speeds.
Either by disability or by
simply stress.
So the core thing I want you to
come away with is don't  design
for yourself.  Design for the
broadest possible markets.   And
you'd be surprised who you're
supporting.  How do you do
this, you ask?  I'm glad you
asked.  One of the ways I talk
about this is a thing called the
curb cut.  A curb cut is that
part of the sidewalk that is
dipped down usually in the
corner  of a block.
This is designed to allow people
with wheelchairs  to be able to
get up onto the sidewalk.
That's really  profoundly
important but it's also useful
for people with
suitcases or babies with
strollers or
bike bikes.  So it can help
many people, but profoundly
people with disabilities.
If you address the needs of
people who are hard of hearing,
you are also helping people who
forgot their ear buds.
For  example, the captions are
helping
people who forgot their ear
buds or on
a noisy train or conversely in a
quiet room where you  don't want
to make a lot
of noise, or even nonnative
speakers.   This one
accommodation can help lots of
people, more people than  you
might realize at the beginning.
Another example, close to my
heart, if you're stuck in an
airplane seat, some of you may
have been on an airplane quite
recently, you put on a headset
but something happened behind
you  but you're strapped and you
can't get around.  What do you
do?
The Google Earth team did one
curb cut where they rotate the
world around you, so you can see
what's happening
behind you be  moved to the
front.
YouTube VR also solved the same
problem by rotating the  world
around you.
You've improved the world for
people in
wheelchairs,  airplane seats or
even your comfy bed.
There are few standards around
VR or AR.  In fact, there  are
none.  So this is an opportunity
to do something really
astounding that really impacts
people's lives.  Even before AR,
people were using devices to
help improve their lives.
People  were using their cameras
on their cell phones to magnify
something.  This is actually an
assistive device
called an  magnifier.
But people were just using this
to magnify something  to make
their life better.  That's the
whole idea.
But with modern AR and VR now,
you can fly anywhere in the
world.  Someone stuck in bed can
visit the international space
station, or you can
measure the couch in your room,
or if the  game is designed as
such you can see when someone is
shooting  from behind you, or
how about when you're stressed
you can have  the most important
piece of information highlighted
or have  everything else be
ignored for you.
This is pretty useful for
everybody.  And fortunately,
each  of these things are also
profoundly impactful for people
with  different kind of
disabilities.
There's lots of ways that AR and
VR can help people,  perhaps in
ways you don't expect.
>> Throughout my career I've had
the opportunity to deal with
people with cancer and seeing
the anxieties they develop.
When  I watch them put on the
headsets you can see immediately
the  change in
their body language and their
facial expressions.
>> My husband tied Tiltbrush.
>> That was a great deal of fun.
>> Subsequently, he went and
bought art supplies and took
classes.
>> It took my mind away from
passively experiencing
something.
>> CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Research
is
being done today showing  that
VR can help people feel less
pain and it can change  people's
lives and introduce a new skill
or talent they never  knew they
had.
A wise man once said with great
power comes  great
responsibility.
How do you start?  One place to
start is with trusted  experts.
For over a decade, able gamers
have helped countless  gamers
with
disabilities either return to
game after
injury or  start playing games
despite a disability.
They worked with  Sony and
Microsoft
to add disability platforms to
their  applications.
Many of the ideas from this talk
come
from this
includification concept.
>> RAN TAO: Let's talk about
what works today.
You see the  new Android
accessibility options and what
it looks like.  Many  work right
out of the box.  Don't worry
about trying to read it.   It's
kind of small.
There's color and contrast
adjustments, color corrections
for different color
deficiencies.
My little brother has a hard
time differentiating between red
and green.  So he turns on this
color correction mode and it
helps him a lot.
Turning on these settings
automatically
applies it to VR  and AR apps.
We can mix right and left
channels into a single channel
and puts those both in a single
ear bud.  You can watch videos
with a single ear bud.
This also works with in AR and
VR.
We have magnification where you
triple tap on the screen to
zoom in.  This works really well
in AR.
We have switch access and talk
back, which I'll get into.
So designing for accessibility,
things that you can do  today,
well, switch
access and talk back requires
the app to  support Android
accessibility API's.  This is
where you come in.
The API's are in Java so you can
integrate them into your  Java
or C++ apps.  The switch access
makes it possible
for  people with dexterity
impairments to use your app with
one or  more switches.  These
switches can take the form of
buttons like  the volume buttons
on the
side of the phone, or special
sensors
like special sensors Hawking had
that detected cheek muscle
switches.
So when you get to the one you
want, you push a second  button
to select it.
Then we have talk back, which is
another way you can  interact
with your phone.
I'll let my friend Victor
demonstrate  it.
>> I'm a technical program
manager on the Android
accessibility services team.
Among other products we work on
talk back.  Talk back is a
screen reader for people who are
blind or vision impaired.
The way you use Talk Back is via
a  special touch gestures.
The algorithm, the feedback is
provided  by speech.  There are
two ways you can navigate the
screen with  talk back.
If first is linear road
integration.  It's performed  by
a single finger.
The user double taps to
activate?
>> AUTOMATED VOICE: Next empty
space,
button, row, turn,  placed the
bottom right.
>> Another method is touch
exploration.  You drag the
finger  across the element on
the screen, towards the element
of  interest is located, and you
tap on it to activate.
>> AUTOMATED VOICE: Next placed
in center left.
Next wins.
>> RAN TAO: Awesome. I'm glad
he won.
That tic-tac-toe app  uses open
GL and
C++ and allowed Android to
interact with them.
It's GitHub.com /resort.
Accessibility should be not an
afterthought.
This is taken  from a recent
trip to Japan.  In Japan they
have a lot of older  houses and
businesses where the
retrofitted with ramps to make
it more accessible.  This ramp
here, I don't know if you
can  tell or not, is like a
45-degree angle.  So I would
just tip  forward if I tried to
go forward.  My girlfriend who
took this  picture as she was
trying to get back up that
ramp she just kept  slipping and
couldn't get back up.  Not sure
what was happening  there.
This is another one.  I still
don't understand what those  are
for.
So start thinking about it
today.
Start testing,  talking, and
listening.  Your users have a
lot to say.
Test with bright sunlight or a
noisy environment or holding  a
cup of coffee in one hand.
Understand your users' needs by
reaching out to the  community.
Reach out to friend or friends
of friends, people  with
different accessibility needs,
and listen to what they have  to
say with an open mind.  They
have valuable perspectives to
share.
And how should you test your
apps?
We think that inclusive  design
shouldn't just be the Java, the
single accessibility  engineer
or a team of engineers.  It
should be considered all  phases
of development, from idea to
design to develop all the  way
to launch.
So we've created this mnemonic
to make it easy to promote
inclusive design
process to all of on your
developers.  And this   mnemonic
is this Saturday morning test.
So imagine for a second  you
woke up
on a Saturday morning, you're
groggy, you forgot  your glasses
and your headphones and you just
want to sit down
in a comfy chair and play some
VR.
Well, this situation simulates a
significant portion of
different accessibility needs.
And if you have perfect vision,
borrow someone's glasses, try
those on.  Make sure of these
four  things: That controls are
simple, the text is
readable, the  items are
reachable, and
the audio is optional.
So again, accessibility is an
important lens of inclusive
design.
Let's dive into the specifics of
how you
can apply  inclusive design to
your immersive applications.
There's many opportunities for
actions and we can break  these
down into four
big categories of accessibility
needs:
Mobility, and dexterity
, visual, audio,
and cognitive.
We'll first cover mobility and
dexterity needs.
We have people with one hand
available, or you're just
holding a cup of coffee.
People with shaky hands or you
drank  too much coffee.  You
have people with limited finger
dexterity  with problems
grasping or pressing buttons, or
people just  wearing gloves.
You have people having a hard
time bending down and getting
things off the
floor or up high off shelves, or
of different  heights, or
difficulty laying down or
sitting down or turning  around,
or perhaps they're in an
airplane seat.
Ever since I started using a
wheelchair, honestly, VR has
been a lot harder.  Tripping
over the cord has been an issue.
It's a lot harder to step offer
the cord in a wheelchair.
I  also, if I'm trying to hold
two
controllers, and trying to push
my chair, it's not really
happening.
Some of the muscles in my hand
also
don't work, so finger
dexterity, so I have trouble
pushing some buttons.
So in a  game, the enemies are
chasing after me, and I can't
press that  sprint button.  I'm
just casually walking away.
(Laughter)
Didn't end well there.
I also have trouble looking
behind me
when things are all  the way
back there.
This is a good opportunity for
us to do a real exercise
together.  If I can get your
participation, please.
Just  indulge me for a second.
Pretend your Luke sky walker,
holding
a light sabre in front of you.
You must defend yourself.
Try to note as you do this
experiment.  The drone is in
front of you.  You're blocking
these shots in front of you.
Now  the drone is to your right.
Turn to your right.  Block those
shots.  Don't feel shy about
your neighbors.  The drone is
behind you.  Turn all the way
behind you.  And then now the
drone is to your left.
So turn 270 degrees to my left.
All  right?
Now the drone is back in front
of you.
So how did you do?
There are some good insights we
can  pull out of this.  Although
it's possible to turn around and
block all of these shots, it's
difficult.  If you're under a
time constraint it makes it
impossible to use this
application.
And you want to really test
these situations yourself.
Don't feel silly.  These are
very valuable insights.  Not
only  does this apply to me; it
applies to you sitting in these
conference chairs.  You don't
want to whack your neighbors
or  the person behind you with
these light sabers.  And you
don't  want to look silly in
this public situations.
Make sure these are useful to
your app in these  experiments.
So how to make your app more
accessible.
As you saw with Google Earth VR
allowing you to rotate the
space around you using the
controller.
There's also the tunnel vision
effect
that blurs out the  surroundings
that creates this grid that
matches your
real-world  coordinates so you
don't get motion sickness.
VR allows you to move places
with the controller.  This is
valuable for someone who wants
to move around without actually
having the space or sitting in a
chair.
It's also valuable to give users
the control to have  incremental
versus smooth rotations and
movements.
That means  versus smoothly
going
around or jumping forward versus
smoothly  gliding forward.
This provides users a choice of
comfort versus finer grain
control.
And then let's talk about
height.  There's users of
different heights.  It's super
common in VR, especially
with  little kids these days
getting real excited about this
technology.
My little sister loves job
simulation.
She couldn't reach  the items
off the shelves.  She's a
13-year-old girl about this
tall.
They added a new shorter human
mode.  You turn it on and  the
world shrinks
into a doll house, like you're a
10-foot  giant.
And she's logged 50 something
hours on this game now.
Generally, you should design to
minimize for reaching down  low
or up high.
Perhaps using a magnetic hand to
grab things  would be one way to
solve this.
Interestingly enough, with three
degrees
of freedom  controllers like on
the
Daydream view and Mirage solo,
there's  more accessible
experiences in the hardware.
There's no need to  reach up or
down.
And custom controls, allowing
users to
choose what works  best for me.
For me remapping that button
allows me to be able  to use
that game again and I can now
run away from the enemies.
And giving assistive controls is
another way to help.
Some  buttons are too small or
not obvious they're
interactable.
Using this bendy laser is one
way to solve that problem.  And
shaky hands from your morning
coffee wouldn't be a problem
anymore, either.
A lot of these come about from
gaming, that are already in
console games.
And will be super valuable in
other apps, as  well.
Like the joy stick, rotations,
et
cetera, allows users to  choose
between finer grain control
versus faster movement.
Let's talk about mobile AR
interactions.
Mobile AR borrows  from mobile
itself.
It's designed for 2DUI but for
3DUI
you  want to have adjustable
size.
It allows people to use your app
in
small spaces but  profoundly
impacts those using your app
stuck in a chair.
For me, I can't really see up
high or reach very far, so I
can move the objects to places
that works best for me.
And having large tap targets.
It forces for simpler user
interfaces, friendlier UI, and
more readable.
Generally, you want the text to
at least be finger size.
And finally, having alternative
gestures, an alternative to
swiping or
shaking the phone, having an
extra tap target to do  these
interactions would be useful.
Now, onto visual impairments.
>> CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Has you
look towards visual
impairments, the groups of
people you'll be supporting are
people without glasses, people
with
glasses, people with high
contrast need, non-stereoscopic
vision, people visually impaired
or blind.
It covers a lot of on different
people throughout  different
phases of life.
One of the most important things
you'll
do is have
multimodel
affordianses.
Have narrative written down, as
well.
And next, support large text and
large fonts, that's so  much
easy to see.
The next one is a contrary, good
contrast, in terms of your  UI.
You probably can't read all the
letters there because I
intentionally made the contrast
bad to reproduce the situation.
If the contrast is bad, it don't
matter.  People can't see it.
If you want to support people
with color blindness, don't  use
only color to support things
like health or progress.
Please use dedicated icons or
textures in addition to color,
so  they can tell the
difference.
And also always try to use a
color blind safe palet.
I do work in accessibility and
AR and VR.
People ask,  well, how do blind
people use AR or VR.  I say
right now it's  really hard.
This is hopefully something we
can work on  together.  At this
time, there's no support in
the major game  engines for
accessibility services.
The UI in 3D   space are just
hanging out there with a  script
attached.  There's no VR check
box or text box.
It's  just a floating texture
that has
a script that allows it to work
like a text box.
There's no window manager or a
way to  understand how to
navigate what these things are.
There's work to be done.
This is actually true within all
3D games as well.
To that  end, please don't
forgot GitHub.com /zork.
If you do want  this, please
reach out to the game
developers.
It's not just  the unholy duo.
Reach out and ask for it so they
can do it.
Moving on towards hearing
impairments.  Here, you're
helping people with
impairments, hearing
impairments, but
also  the noisy environment or
the quieter environments or
people  without their
headphones.
There's the multimodel
affordances, again.
Captions, narrations, it's the
same idea but different
instances.
Captions are normally video.
Narrations are cut scenes of the
game.
Please include the captions or
narration in these things so
everyone can enjoy the story
you're building.
Often, if you have avatars in VR
or AR, we find captions  are
often connected to a word or
thought bubble.  That's pretty
useful as long as people know
where to look.
So be careful with  that.
In terms of captions, this is
really important.
Unfortunately, not all platforms
support closed captioning in
VR.  YouTube VR has always
supported captions.  And the way
YouTube VR does it is called
head locked.
It's this little  black box with
white letters.
As you turn your head, it spins
around with you.  There's no way
for us to tell where for it to
go, but at least it's there.
But again, not all VR platforms
support this.  If you have
video or are using video in an
application, please burn it into
the video.  It's not the best
solution.  The best solution is
to  support captions, but if you
can't, please at least do this.
And when you're doing this,
there's sort of two standards
most  common.  One is a
three-up, like you see here.
It's 12, 4, and  7.
The idea here is to make sure
there's always some bit of  the
captions
available in the peripheral
vision so you know  something is
happening.
But what's becoming more common
is
north, south, east,  west, or
all the same side of the cube.
Put your captions in  these
places and everyone should be
able to find them.
There's a new format called VR
180 which
we just announced  with Lenovo
mirage.  When you go into
YouTube, put
everything in  a 16 by 9 crop
and everything should be visible
there and that  works just fine.
Moving on to what's cognitive
impairments.
The people that  you help here
are distracted users, like
parents, people with  difficulty
remembering or understanding
language, like parents.   Or
foreign language speakers.  And
what you do here, you want to
make your UI simple and easy to
use.
This is simplify,  simplify,
simplify.
Think about the uses of your
video or use of UI, how to
guide someone from one idea to
the next.  Make it intuitive,
not  just beautiful.
If you're talking about
situations where you have
levels,  there's three things
that are useful.  One is have a
sandbox  level for people who
have a hard time learning or
hard time  manipulating
controls.  Give them a place
where they can mess  around and
learn how to use your game or
your experience without  having
it impact their ability to
actually play the game moving
forward.
If you can't do that, make sure
you have a good training.   So
give people a safe place, an
opportunity to learn how to
build and play your game, how to
use your interaction.
Finally, have different
difficulty modes.  It's the
standard easy, medium, and hard,
but you don't want to be mean.
You don't want to tell anybody
you're going easy to them.  I
like the story balance and
challenge that some games have
talked  about.
It's a lot nicer, but it gets
the same idea.
If you want someone to hear your
story, don't stop them.   Let
them play to their ability.
Finally, sometimes people just
can't get through the level.
So why should they be stopped in
the process of getting through
your story?  In this case, come
up with an auto pass.
Say, if  you can't get past it
in ten times, ask, "Do you want
to move on  to the next level?"
So they can see what your story
is.
Sometimes they'll say yes;
sometimes no.  But why prevent
them from having the choice?
Auto pass is a nice way to help
people understand and finish the
work that you've done.
Now taking the step up from sort
of the game environment.
About an hour ago my team in
central disability has just
announced an application called
Lookout.  It's an AR application
that uses the
camera and visual detection of
the world around  you and
provides an audio description of
the world around you.
In an image here, on the left,
we have a picture of  lavender.
It's a captioner that says
lavender.
You would hear  "lavender at
12:00 o'clock" on the right-hand
side we have a  series of
contexts.
The important thing, there's
three things I want to talk
about here that are important.
That context menu is actually
surprisingly important because
until we know your context, we
don't know what
to say or more importantly we
don't know what  not to say.
If we don't know what you care
about, we'll read everything  to
you.  If I had this right here,
I'd say person, person,  person,
person, person, person.  And
it's all correct, but it
doesn't matter.  So providing
the context gives you an
opportunity to not just say the
things that matter in real-time.
The second thing is a blind user
uses the camera very
differently than you expect.
It's really true.
When testing all our engineers,
because
they're sighted,  would
generally
localize the camera on certain
things.
But when  we tested it, boy,
they were localizing on
different things.
So we had to go to a very, very
large
imagine and resolve  it, and
then finally we got to what
we're looking for.
And then finally, spatialness.
If there's lavender in  front of
you,
it makes it different than 12:00
o'clock,  2:00 o'clock, or 1:00
o'clock.  So that sense of space
of where  things are is really
important in terms of
understanding the  world around
you.
So in conclusion, y'all can wake
up now.  Please don't  forget
these key points.  One, don't
design for yourself or your
situation.
Two, test, talk, and listen.
Sit down and take the  Saturday
morning test.  Check that
controls are simple.  Text is
readable, items are reachable.
Audio is optional.  And think
about the different types
of needs from mobility, visual,
auditory, and cognitive.
>> CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: What are
your curb cuts?  What is
something that you can do to
helps everybody but has a
profound  impact on someone with
disabilities?  And if you
remembered  nothing else,
you can also go to Able Gamers'
Gamers' includeification.
>> RAN TAO: We want to hear
from you.  Provide feedback from
our session.  There's our link.
Thank you so much for attending
our talk.
>> CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Thank
you.
(Applause)
(End session.
)
Prepare
blank
GOOGLE I/O
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 08, 2018
STAGE 4
4:004:00 P.M.
PT
GROW AND OPTIMIZE YOUR
SUBSCRIPTIONS
WITH NEW GOOGLE PLAY  FEATURES
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
* * *
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of proceedings. This
text, document, or file is not
to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
* * *
(Music)
>> All right. Good afternoon,
everyone.
I want to give a  special shout
out to all the people around the
world right now  watching us on
the live stream.  My name is
Larry Yang.
I'm a  product manager on the
Google play billing platform.
I'm joined  by Angela and Niko
today.  Say hi, everyone.
>> Hi.
>> Hi, everybody.
>> LARRY YANG: Let's kick
things off with a quick show of
hands.  Who here is already
running a subscriptions business
on  Google Play?  Wow, that's
over half the room.  That's
awesome.
All right.  Who here is looking
to get started on running a
subscriptions business on Play?
All right.  That's about a
third of the room.
That's awesome.
Well, I have good news for all
of you.  Today, we're going  to
run through a whole bunch of
features and capabilities that
you can use right now to start a
subscriptions business, whether
you're already -- already have
an existing business and you're
looking to optimize your growth
or if you're just looking to get
something started.
But before we jump in, let's
take a quick look at why we're
even all here talking about
subscriptions.
Subscriptions is one of the
fastest growing businesses on
mobile today.  It's no surprise
users have been telling us that
they love subscriptions.  They
love the value that
subscriptions  provide and they
love the access to
continuous fresh content  that
get via a subscription service.
Users have demonstrated  this
love by making a subscriptions a
part of their daily lives.
In fact, 62% of paid Android
subscribers use their
subscription  app at least once
every single day.
And because users love
subscriptions, developers love
them,  too.
Let's watch a short video
highlighting some of the great
success that you
developers have had on
subscriptions on Google  Play.
(Music)
>> LARRY YANG: All right.
Let's pretty cool, huh?  So this
is a real testament to all the
great work that you developers
have done on subscriptions on
Google Play.
But together, we can do so much
more.
So today -- first, we'll recap
some of the features
we rolled  out recently and some
of the developers that we've
seen with  those features.
Next we'll roll out a dozen new
features
that you can put  to work right
away to help roll out your
business.
Finally, we'll give a sneak peek
to what's around the  corner but
more importantly what you can do
today to be ready  when those
features are available.
Niko, why don't you come up on
and get us started and tell  us
about successes that developers
have having today.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Thanks, Larry.
The past 12 months have  been
truly exciting for subscriptions
on Google Play.
We as a  team have worked hard
to address the biggest
challenges you are  facing as
developers.
For example, minimizing churn.
Quickly, I want to run through
three features we have seen
successful
developers use to do just that.
Number one is  real-time
developer notifications.
Real-time developer
notifications
give you immediate notifications
when the  subscriber state
changes like they renew or
cancel.
Essentially, it changes the way
you operate your  subscription
business on Google Play,
especially in regards to
minimizing subscriber churn.
Let me quote two top developers
on this feature.
One says  reality notificationed
have
helped them identify the exact
moment a user cancels so they
can remind them of
the benefits of  subscription
and entice
them to resubscribe.
They like real-time developer
notifications because it lets
them
predict subscriber churn in
reality and quickly win back
users with offers.
The bottom line is, for
developers serious about
retention,  real-time developer
notifications have become a
must.
Secondly, we invested quite a
bit in
helping you combat  involuntary
churn because it's just so
painful.  You spend all  this
time building a
great product or service, and
then you  convince users to
become subscribers to your
product, just so  they may
churn,
because, for example, they
forgot to update  their form of
payment.
That's why we've seen such great
success
with a grace  period which
allows us to
retry to charge subscribers
whose  payment has failed for a
defined period of time,
an account hold  which lets you
put subscribers in a suspended
state until they  update their
form of payment.
As you can see here in the
example
provided by our partner  music
match that's notifying the user
about a payment that has
failed.
Lastly, we have heard really
great feedback on the Play
subscription
reports we launched at I/O last
year on this stage.   Actually,
over there.
And now it provides many ways to
analyze
your business and  find
optimization potential.
Developers have made it the
primary destination for
business intelligence for
anybody working on subscriptions
in  their company.
So to quickly summarize, our
most successful  developers show
us how these features help them
build great  subscription
services today, so we recommend
all of you to check  them out if
you're not already using them
anyways.
Okay.  Enough of features you
already know.  I want to
welcome Angela to tell you all
about the new things we're
announcing.
>> ANGELA YING: Thanks, Niko.
(Applause)
>> ANGELA YING: We've talked
about how much users love
subscriptions.  We strongly
believe that by building a
great  user experience, we are
also building a high quality
subscriber  base.
But we know that the user
experience is not always
perfect.
So just taking a quick straw
poll out there, how many of you
have hesitated to sign up for a
subscription service because you
thought it would be too annoying
to cancel or it would just be a
hassle to remember?  I know I
have.
I see a bunch of you guys  have,
as well.  And this is what we
found on your user research.
Users told us while they can
derive a lot of value out of
their  subscriptions
once they've signed up, they
feel like they'll be  trapped
within the subscription without
the ability to cancel.
Since the majority of our users
have multiple subscriptions  to
manage, they're worried they'll
lose track of how much  they're
spending.
These fears create a barrier for
users signing up for your
subscription apps and we want to
address that fear.
So we're really excited to
announce that
we're launching a  new
subscription center.
This is a one-stop-shop for
users to  manage their
subscriptions in Google Play.
We've done a complete U.S.
overhaul of our old
subscriptions page to make it
easier for users to get more
information about their
subscription, easily fix their
payment  issues, and do other
actions such as restore their
subscription.
Rather than talk about it, let
me show you how it works.
Niko has graciously volunteered
to be my demo person.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Yes.
>> ANGELA YING: Can I get two
forward on the slides, please?
Okay.  We're just going to do
this.  (Laughter)
>> NIKO SCHROER: You want to go
to the demo?
>> ANGELA YING: Yeah. Let's go
to demo A.  Yeah.   (Laughter).
Niko, can you open the Play
Store and open the hamburger
menu?
Okay.
So we're looking at Vincent
Verily's account.
We can  see the subscriptions is
now really prominently placed on
the  hamburger menu.  Let's see
what happens when we go to the
subscription.
Vincent doesn't have any
subscriptions but there's a "get
started" link.  Let's see what
happens when we tap it.  We see
there's a whole new selection of
different subscription apps
that the users can explore.
And keep in mind this is not the
vinyl version.  This is
something that our amazing
merchandising team is working on
making a better experience day
after day.
So let's actually see what the
subscription center looks  when
the user has some subscriptions.
Can you switch to Wendy's
account, please?
?
Okay.  We can see that Wendy
actually has three subscriptions
in her account.  One of them has
a payment decline which needs
to be addressed but in
general we can see that she has
all this  information about her
subscription, including SKU name
which is  something we didn't
have before.
In order to go in and manage a
specific
subscription, we  just have to
tap somewhere.
Niko, let's tap on
Pearl and Straw  to manage that
subscription.
Let's say she wants to update
that payment method.
So Niko, let's tap update under
"primary payment method.  "
So now we can see all the
payment methods that Wendy has
in  her account.  Let's go ahead
and switch that to the
new -- to  the new credit card.
So we've actually launched a
cool new feature
(Music being played over audio
to captioner)
This is also a new feature that
we have already launched and  is
available.
Let's go ahead and get that old
credit as a  backup.
(Music still playing over
speaking in
audio to captioner.
)
>> ANGELA YING: Okay. With the
launch in the subscription
center, we're also launching new
seedlings specifically designed
for development.
...
Oh, man, I wanted to access that
premium article about Yak  but
all I see is a dead Yak.
So I guess let's see what
happens.
Okay.  Now I'm in the manage
subscription
page for the Yak app.
There's a problem with my
account.
There's also a CTA for  me to
fix this problem.
Let's go ahead and fix that
problem.
(Audio problem
>> Nice.
Payment is fixed and we're back
to the premium  experience.
Let's cut back to the slides,
please.
This is a feature that many,
many of you have asked for.
And you can access the survey
answers
through our server  site API
today.  Eventually, you'll also
be able to see the  answers in
console reporting.
We're still rolling out the user
face changes.
If you query it today, you'll
see a small percentage of the
answers that users have already
input.
Let's get back to the demo to
see how this works.
So Niko let's go to the Play
Store and
to Wendy's account  again.
So Wendy is not only a big fan
of Yak, she also loves
Narwhals, but she's
gotten kind of tired of the
Narwhal monthly  newsletter.  So
let's cancel that subscription
for her.  Let's  go into
Narwhal.  It's easy.  We just
tap cancel subscription.
Now, what we see is a quick user
-- is a quick survey for  the
user to give the developer some
feedback as to why they're
canceling.
There are already a few
pre-written answers but Wendy
has a  pretty specific reason,
and can select "other" to type
in that  reason.
Niko, she told you what that
reason was, right?
>> NIKO SCHROER: She did,
indeed.
She said there are not  enough
Narwhals.
>> ANGELA YING: I mean, I guess
they are an endangered  species,
so that makes sense.
Let's finish canceling that
subscription.  Cool.
The nice thing is, even if
tomorrow Wendy wakes up and she
realized she made a huge
mistake, she can actually go
back and  restore her
subscription in the subscription
center.
Let's go ahead and restore that
subscription.
Awesome.
So now Wendy can continue to
enjoy her Narwhal subscription
even next month.
And that's it for the demo.
Let's go back to the
presentation.
(Applause)
at Google, we always believed in
you
focus on the user, all  else
will follow.  Because of this
new user first experience to
easily manage subscriptions,
users will trust our store and
engage more with your apps.
With the subscription center
we'll also be able to deliver
more capabilities to you, the
developer.
The deep link and cancel survey
are just to samples of the
abilities.
Let's go back to Larry and Niko
to talk about the other new
developments we're coming out
with.
>> LARRY YANG: Thank you,
Angela.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Thank you,
Can we get applause for
flawless demo execution?
(Applause)
So I'm part of the Google Play
development team.
The Google  Play business
development team works directly
with subscription  developers
with all kinds of backgrounds
around the world.   Naturally,
we hear a lot of feedback and
ideas for features  which we
then
take to our PM teams, such as
Larry or Angela, to  see how we
can solve these things we hear
about.
So one of the requests is that
you developers told us you  want
more
flexibility in issuing refunds
to your users.
Currently, under service-side
API, you can only refund the
latest subscription order using
the purchase token.
You cannot  issue a refund using
the order ID, issue a refund for
previous  subscription orders,
or partial refunds.
That's really not  ideal when
dealing with subscribers.
>> LARRY YANG: Well, I have
great news for you, Niko, and
everyone here.  We've now closed
these gaps.
We're supporting  refunds using
order ID's.  You think refund a
subscription  renewal, not just
the latest one.
And starting today you can  also
issue partial refunds, on the
Play Console.  You can go to
our sandbox afterwards and see a
demo of that in action.  This
feature will also be available
on our server-side API next
week.
>> NIKO SCHROER: I'm sure that
will make a lot of developers
really happy.
Another request we've heard a
lot, it's maybe the longest
standing feature
request that I personally know
of, is price  changes.
At the moment, you cannot change
the price of an SKU once  it's
been created.  Obviously, that's
very limiting for  businesses,
especially for businesses whose
costs have gone up.
So currently, the only way to do
this is
to create a new  SKU and get
users to upgrade.
That also means that you, the
developers, have to do all  the
heavy
lifting, like messaging users or
cancels users who  don't
upgrade.
>> LARRY YANG: So we've heard
so much about this feature  from
Niko and other business
development partners we figured
the  easiest way to make them
happy was to just build the
feature.
I'm pleased to announce we now
support mandatory price changes
on existing SKUs.
(Applause)
>> LARRY YANG: All right.
Yeah, see?  You made everyone
happy now.
>> NIKO SCHROER: I told you.
>> LARRY YANG: Let's say you
need to roll out a price change
to all your users.  Maybe your
cost of content has gone up or
the tax structure has changed in
one of the countries you do
business in.
So now all you need to do is go
to the Play Console, choose  the
country or countries where you
need to change the
price,  enter the new price, and
click "save" and you're done.
30 days before the user's
renewal date,
we, Play, start  sending emails
and push notifications asking
the user to agree  to that price
change.
We also give you the developer a
seven-day head start so  you can
also message the user in-app.
If that renewal date comes and
the user has not agreed to  the
price change, we
will take care of canceling that
user.
This feature is currently in
early access.  If you're
interested in trying it out, and
joining our early access
program, please visit the link
that you see on the screen here.
>> NIKO SCHROER: I think it's
so
awesome that we finally let
developers do that, give you
that flexibility to actually run
your business.
I'm sure developers will love
this flexibility in building
their subscription business on
Play.
Which actually brings me so
another ask.
I mentioned early earlier how
much developers love
subscription reports and that
retention is the key topic.
So what we've heard quite a bit
is  that you developers ask for
reports that provide even more
details especially on
the topics of retentions and
cancellations.
I know we have a lot to share
here.  You want to jump right
in?
>> LARRY YANG: Yep. We have a
lot of great news in this  area,
as well.
In I/O last year we announced a
brand new  subscriptions
dashboard.
A lot of developers told us they
love  the reports and many use
them every day to get insights
into  your business.  But you
all asked for more
capabilities, which  is why we
extended
two new capabilities in our
extensions  report.  Let's take
a quick look at what they are.
First, we're creating a new
retention report.  Now, it's
super easy to go in and
look at specific cohorts, say by
SKU or  dates or by country.
Now, you can also drill into
your free-trial conversion,  and
other interesting metrics in
this report.
And you can also look
specifically at how many renewal
periods various users in the
cohorts have advanced through.
After all, that's the name of
the game
when you're running  a
subscriptions business.
So the second change we're
making is
we're making  improvements to
the cancellation report.
Here is where you will see the
data from the cancellations
survey that Angela and Niko
showed you earlier.
And we'll also give you details
on how your win-back and
retention features
are performing, such as account
hold and  grace period.
All in all, this feature will be
rolling
out over the next  few weeks and
will help people like you
optimize your entire  life
cycle.
You can get detailed on the new
reporting capabilities in
tomorrow's session on analyzing
and bunch marking over on stage
3 at 9:30 tomorrow morning.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Are you done
now?
>> LARRY YANG: I have a few
more things I have to squeeze
in.
Our engineers have so much
stuff.  Give me a few more
seconds.  I wish we had more
time.  They told us they'd cut
us  off at the end of this
session.  Real quick here.  I
want to  share with you all, you
all have asked for the ability
to do  quicker renewals on your
test subscriptions so we rolled
that  capability out.  For
example, a monthly test
subscription will  now renew in
just five minutes.
You also wanted the ability to
create an intro price period
that's different from your
regular reoccurrence period.
So we've now rolled out that
capability, so you could say,
for example, offer a dollar for
90 days and then kick into
$10 a  month on y subscription.
Finally, we have the capability
for you
to offer an upgrade  but keep
the user's
renewal date and charge an
incremental  prorated price.
This is only available with the
Play billing  library.  Which
you'll hear more about later.
>> ANGELA YING: Thanks. Let's
recap.  We launched 12 new
features in total, both for
users and developers.  On the
user  side we created a better
user experience with the new
subscription center, including
app
discovery, backup payment
method, new deep linking, and a
cancel survey.
For the developer, we're giving
you a ton more flexibility,
including
improved refunds, ability to
change SKU
prices, and  band supporting,
and more.
We've bolded the features that
are available now.
So go  check them out as soon as
you can.
All these other features we're
working on rolling out in  the
next couple of weeks.
So these are the features that
we've been working on this  past
year.
But what are we going to do next
year and the year after  that?
Larry, you want to tell them
more?
>> LARRY YANG: Yes.
So these features we just shared
are  things you can use right
now to grow your business, but
we're  not done.
Our engineers are hard at work
coming up with new features
that will help you
acquire and retain your
subscribers.
For example, imagine if your
users could sign up outside of
your app, say from the Play
Store or anywhere else on the
web.
Or what if your users could pay
with cash?
What if we offered the option
for users
to temporary
ily pause  their subscription
instead of
outright canceling them,
or we  could help you win back
your subscribers long after they
cancel  subscription?
>> NIKO SCHROER: That sounds
exciting, but does that mean
every time we come up with a new
feature the developers have to
rewrite the code?
>> LARRY YANG: Our goal is to
build these features in a way
that you have to do as little
work as possible.  Our goal is
as  close as possible to zero
integration.  We want that to
happen  on both the client said
with your app as well as on
your  server-side integration.
>> NIKO SCHROER: That sounds
great but how are you going to
do that?
>> LARRY YANG: Just relax.
Give me a few minutes I'll talk
through how we're going to make
this happen.  All right?
First, let's talk about what you
need to do on your client  side.
Last fall at Play time we
announced
version 1.0 of the Play  billing
library.
It's an abstraction label on
top...
when you  update your build
dependency file and the next
time you exile  your app.
Now, there's no for searching
reference code and sample  code
and copying it and hoping you
got the right version and all
that.
It's all taken care of
automatically.
Today, we're announcing 1.1
version of the Play billing
library.  This includes the
feature I mentioned earlier
where  you can upgrade and keep
the ex pirration date.
When we roll out the price
changes, that
will also be  available only via
the Play billing library.
Using the Play Billing Library
is very, very simple.   There's
three easy steps.  Now, since no
I/O presentation is  complete
without showing some code, I'm
going to go and show a  few code
examples for this.
You're probably thinking, oh,
no, we're near the end of the
session and now you're going to
show me a bunch of code.  Don't
worry.  The whole point of
showing this code is to show you
really how little code it takes
to use the Billing Library.
First, all you need to do is add
this one line to your
dependency file.
Second, you need to create the
billing client instance.
To do that, set up the listener.
And connect to Google  Play.
Of course, don't forget to build
your
own retry policy in  case your
client loses connection.
The third and final step is, of
course, to call the proper
method as you go through your
purchase life cycle, just like
you  do today.
That's it.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Okay. I'm
convinced.  It's so
straightforward that even I get
it.
It's actually very close to zero
integration.
But still, it's late afternoon.
And I think we've had  enough
slides with code.
So at the end of the day what
really  matters is how
developers actually like it.
My favorite quote is from Joe
Birch.
He's a Google  developer expert
who
called Google Play Billing
Library a "dream  come true."
We're making this dream come
true for thousands of developers
today already.
So if you, like me, did not
memorize the code on those
slides, note on this link
here, on the slide, to learn
more.
>> LARRY YANG: So remember,
with the Play Billing Library,
one, integration is much, much
simpler.  A lot less code to
manage.
New features will be rolling out
in the
future will only be  available
using the Play Billing Library.
Currently, it's only available
for Java and Kotland  developers
but a C++ version is coming
soon.
So that's on the client side.
Here is what you need to do  on
is server side.
Earlier we talked about
real-time developer
notifications.   Let me talk
about what it is and how you can
use it today and  how it will
prepare you for the future.
So with real-time developer
notifications, you set up a
Google
Cloud integration and we send
you
real-time messages when
important events happen like,
for example, when you have a new
user that signings up or
an existing user that renews and
it  sends up a message and now
you need to
grant a new entitlement  or
continue to grant entitlement to
that user.
If today you integrated and
implemented
account hold, and  by the way in
case
you weren't looking in that
video, you  really, really
should integrate with
account hold, we send you a
real-time
developer notifications when the
user as a payment  issue and
goes on hold or recovers their
payment issue and goes  off
hold.
Now immediately you'll know when
to with hold or grant
entitlement to that user.
This is super important if you
have a service that operates
cross-platform.
Say you have users that sign up
on
Android or  might consume on web
or other mobile platforms.
Real-time developer
notifications also tell you
about  voluntary canceltion,
where the user chooses to
cancel.
In this situation, when you get
that message, right away  you
should start trying to win back
that user, maybe remind the
user about some new content
that's coming up or tell them
about  some features they
noticed you haven't used in your
app.
And using the deep link Angela
told you about earlier, you
then drive the user back to the
subscription center where
they  click on the "restore"
button and with one tap they
become an  active subscriber
again.
These are some of the things you
can do today, right now,  with
real-time developer
notifications.
But in the future, if you
integrate now, you'll be ready
for some of the new
things that we'll be rolling
out, like
say  your user temporarily
pauses their subscription.
We'll send you  a real-time
developer notifications so
you'll know that  happened.
Or if you got a user to
reactivate their subscription
after  it expired.  You'll get a
real-time developer
notifications and  you now know
to grant entitlement back.
Remember, with real-time
developer notifications, the
notification is only telling you
the subscription state changed.
You still need to call and query
the full state of the
subscription and know exactly
what action you need to take
with  that subscri.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Real-time
developer notifications has
become an essential
part of our top developer
subscription  setup.  Check out
the details of how to set
this up under this  link which
takes you to the developer page
with all the details.
>> LARRY YANG: Remember, if you
want to future proof your
integration, be sure
to use both the Play Billing
Library and  the real-time
developer notifications.
Whew, that was a lot of stuff.
Give us a lot of stuff.   We'll
real quick recap all the stuff
we introduced and told you
about.
>> NIKO SCHROER: We started off
talking about how much users
love subscriptions thanks to the
great work you've done and the
great products and subscription
services you've launched and are
operating.
>> ANGELA YING: We shared with
you 12 new features,  including
many built
around the new subscription
center.
>> LARRY YANG: Finally, you can
integrate with real-time
developer notifications so
you're ready with new
features, and  we talked about
Play Billing Library.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Obviously,
this is only day one of I/O.
There are great sessions to
check out.  We recommend the
6:00 p.m. session on games today
which will also talk about
subscriptions and games.
Tomorrow at 9:30, you can learn
much  more about all the great
reports we only touched on
today.
>> ANGELA YING: You can also
check out demos of a lot of
features we've announced in the
sandbox, which is over there.
And we also have an office hours
specifically for Google Play
subscriptions tomorrow at 2:30
p.m.
>> LARRY YANG: If you have more
questions, join us in the
Android play conversation area
just on the other side of the
wooden deck to your right as you
walk out, right after this
session.
Lastly, we would love to get
your feedback.
After all, how  is Niko going to
get better at his jokes if we
don't give him  feedback?
Okay.  That's it, everyone.
Thank you very much and enjoy
the
rest of your I/O.
>> NIKO SCHROER: Thank you.
(Applause)
(End session
at
4:
4:35 p.m. PT.
)
(Music)
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 08, 2018
STAGE 4
5:00 P.M.
PT
BUILD GREAT MATERIAL DESIGN
PRODUCTS
ACROSS PLATFORMS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
* * *
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of proceedings. This
text, document, or file is not
to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
* * *
(Music)
>> Hello. Welcome to our talk.
My name is Jonathan Chung.   I'm
a U.S. lead to Material Design
team.
>> NICK BUTCHER: I'm Nick
Butcher and a
design engineer on  the team.
>> WILL LARCHE: And I'm Will.
I'm an engineer with Material
Design.
>> JONATHAN CHUNG: Today we're
excited
to talk about how to  build
Material Design product across
platform.  Again, what is
Material Design, given all the
new announcements we just made,
how has it evolved from what we
knew before?
Material Design is an adaptable
design
system, backed by  open-source
code that helps teams easily
build high quality  digital
experiences.
In other words, it helps you
build beautiful and usable
products really fast.
In 2014, when we first launched,
we had zero customers.
Now,  we have over 1.5 million
apps using Material Design.
That is incredible.  And based
on this huge number of
customers, we've really listened
and
continued to improve our
system.
So today, we launched material
theming,
our end-to-end  product
capability that makes it easy to
make Material Design  yours.
Now, I'm sure some of you are
very eager to learn more, but
maybe some of you are still
wondering if Material Design is
appropriate for you, and for
your company.
So I'm going to start off by
walking
through the newly  designed
Material.iO site.
And then Nick will talk about
Material
Design tools that will  make
customization really effortless.
And then Will will talk about a
library
of open-source code  that can be
used across all platforms.
Let me give you three reasons
why you should really consider
using Material Design.
First, Material Design is also
for developers.
You've given us a lot of
feedback that it has not been
easy  for you to apply and build
apps using Material Design.
Now, with Material theming and
all the
tools we built to  support this
new capability, we're now
imparting designers to  create
with an eye towards the code
that you will be developing.
Material Design is a truly
cross-platform framework.  We
understand how critical it is to
build a consistent user
experience that works across
platforms.
Using Material Design will
benefit your
users using multiple  devices.
We also understand that building
high quality products takes  a
long time.
So not only we're encouraging
cross-platform consistency, but
also
providing the code to start
developing
on Android, iOS,  Web, and
Flutter.
Now we're going to put that to
the test.
Imagine building a screen like
this.  In my experience,
building a screen like this and
doing it right will likely take
some time.
With the power of Material
Design, we're now making it
easier  than ever to design and
build screens like this across
platforms.
All that magic starts right here
with the redesigned site.
The new site is now broken into
design, develop, and tools.
And in each of those sections,
you'll find all of the great
resources that our team has
created for you.
Design guidelines, tools,
research
insights, open open-source
code, you name it, it's all
there.
We're going to check out the
site in greater detail now.
The design section still has
everything that you loved about
Material Design.  It's all
there.  Nothing is gone.
In addition, we're now featuring
some of the most-read  articles
on the top of
the page to help you find
content faster.
We're still very much focused on
helping
you design products  that are
beautiful, with our background
and design.
Here you can see the articles we
provided for you and learn
about system
icons, generate your own
custom-color
palette, pick  a typeface that
works for
your brand and really harness
the  power of shapes in your UI.
The last section talks about
material studies, which we
showcase all the flexibility of
Material Design, regardless if
you're building for retail, for
communications, or even
something as complex as a travel
app.
It's all there and we've tested
it, and
it's all there for  you to check
out.
The Material Design guidance has
also been expanded and  enhanced
into
Material system, Material
foundation and Material
guidelines.
Starting with the Material
system section we're giving you
the general overview of Material
metaphors.
Then the foundation dives into
the
foundational UI practices,  so
mentions
structural things like color,
iconography, shape,  layout, and
more.
Now, the guidelines section
gives
tactical guidance on how to
create a material product.
And the best thing about this is
that
all of these great  design
guidelines
are closely linked with
engineering.
Now, let's take a look at some
of the other features on the
site that's going to be helpful
for you when you're building
your product.
We know how having a detailed
spec makes the engineering
process ten times faster.
That's why we're providing this
view  called spec viewer in the
articles.
In this spec viewer, we're now
exposing all of the useful
information about this image.
Clicking through the menu on the
right,
you'll have access to  all of
the
different types of layers about
this image.  You can  just read
the image only, see the
measurements, text, color,
shape and elevation, see the
different
components used in this  UI, or
even additional notes we might
have added.
Let's take a look at this text
annotation.
So in this annotation you will
not only see the font name,
size, and color, but
also link to a Google font site
that our  team has built.
We wanted to serve these useful
resources to you in the  context
of your work flow so everything
you need is right there.
Now, when you navigate to the
Google font sites, you will be
able to
download and use any of the
fonts used
in our moths.
We also conducted research on
the most effective ways to
deliver the guidelines and we
found interactive content
increased the level of
understanding for our readers.
We're starting to introduce
content that is interactive in
our articles.
Here is an example of a Material
palet generator placed  online
with the article.
Through this tool you'll be able
to
learn about the improved  color
system.
.
So those are some new features
we're adding to the design
section, but how do you build
all this?  That's what you're
here  for, right?
The develop section now features
and has
access to all of the
open-source code
for Android, iOS, Web, and
Flutter.
So while respecting the platform
conventions, we wanted to  make
sure it
works across platforms and not
just on Android.
And you'll be able to play with
these components in our
catalogs.
If you scroll down, you can see
the section called developer
resources.  So similar to the
design section, we
wanted to  provide the resources
that you can use to build your
product.
Let's say you're not as familiar
with any of this.  Scroll to
the bottom even more.  And
you'll find tutorials to get
started  on this.
Switching gears to the tools
section.  So the tools section
has links to all of the great
resources we built for you.
Starting with gallery, which is
a part that I love and have
been using to
share designs with my team, I
love this product,  gallery.
Gallery makes collaboration so
easy and so seamless.
Nick will give you more details
about gallery in a minute.
On the right you will have
access to the five full sets of
stylized icons
available in a range of formats,
sizes, and  densities.
In the bottom, you will see the
material theme editor or
sketch.  What is a theme editor?
If you haven't heard from  other
talks
already, the theme editor is a
plug-in that lets you  express
your brand
through color, iconography,
typography, and  shape.
Through the theme editor you'll
be able
to pick the themes we  provided
for you and customize it to make
it yourself.
These sets of components,can be
used in your designs right
away.
What's great about the theme
editor is all our guidances
mentioned in our
guidelines is directly integrate
into .
What if you want to change
something later on?  No problem.
Here is an example of choosing a
color from the material color
pallet
and applying it to the entire
library of components.  I  find
this so useful and makes it to
easy.
Now I'll hand it off to my
colleague Nick to talk about the
editor.
>> NICK BUTCHER: Thanks,
Jonathan.
So we've seen how the materials
system and guidelines makes  it
easy to bring your unique brand
into your apps.
I'll walk you through an example
how you do this to  demonstrate
how easy it is
to do and show you how the
material  tooling makes this
process from design through
development much  faster.
I was part of an awesome team
that
designed and build the  Google
I/O app.  Maybe some of you have
used it.  There are some  new
components in here.
But we didn't want to use all
the new
Material capabilities because we
didn't
want to spoil the fun  today.
So I'm going to talk about how
to bring this brand much  deeper
into application.
We like to think of this as a
developer festival, almost.
There's a lot of playfulness in
this brand.  I like the motion
style.
It's also expressed through the
color pallet, which you
hopefully see all around you.
It also picks up on things likes
layering and stats.
We use  that as the illustration
style
as a kind of mark of the brand.
How can we apply these elements
into the app design?
Here I am in sketch.
This is my design file generated
by
the  theme editor that Johnny
just showed you.
You see it's generated a bunch
of stuff
for us, a bunch of  components,
typography, scale, elevation
settings, so on and so  forth.
If I switch to the components
view here,
you can see there's  basically a
one-to-one for all the
components and
guidelines  generated for me,
ready to use in my designs.
Everything from back drops, from
fabs, to cards, you name it;
it's in here.
The best thing about these
components
and they're aware of  the
Material theming system.
Let me show you what I mean by
that.  I switch back to the
theme, and open
up the theme editor from the
sketch plug-ins  menu.
This theme is set up using the
I/O
indigo primary and  kind of teal
accent color.
If I go to the color settings,
and I
were to change this  primary
color either by dragging around
or putting it directly,  it will
have a number of effects.  I'll
walk you through them.
You notice this tonal palate.
It's generated 10 different
tones of color from this one
color I chose.  This is pretty
cool.  I'm going to geek out on
this a little bit.
It's not just being naive and
taking the hue I selected and
doing the brightness and
selecting the color that way.
It's  trying to imitate how
designers pick colors and it's
using that,  which hopefully
will work great throughout your
application.
By selecting that, you can see
the entire color palate here
has been updated.
If I switch back to the
components, the sticky sheet,
they're  all aware of that
change in the theme color and
the change is  rippled out
throughout all the elements.
There's a darker tone  for the
status bar and so forth, which
is pretty powerful.
So how do we use this library we
generated?
So switching over into my app
design file, this is some
screens from the I/O app which I
designed using those
components  in the library that
theme
editor  editor generated for me.
If you haven't used the sketch's
library feature it's pretty
cool.  It's a way to share
components between different
design  files or amongst your
team.  It's very powerful.
You access the library, and you
scroll down to this library I
generated.  You see right here
all the components I just saw in
the sticky sheets nicely
arranged in this kind of tree
structure.  We can choose the
component we want, the different
variance of the component, even
down to the different states the
component can be in.
If I want to add a fab to my
design, I can grab one from the
menu and drop it in.
You can see overrides allowing
you to
change the icon and so  on and
so forth.
So through theme editor you have
a huge array of components  you
can use.
So we understand the library how
it's
generated and that, but  let's
start customizing.
I open up my editor.
One of the first premise that
might be  interesting from the
I/O brand is shape.
You have this I and  prominent
slash in between.
I think it could be interesting
to do the surface shape
treatment.
We have this rounded corner
surface shape.
I'm going to switch to the
angled
setting instead, and crank  up
the corner radius on the top
left.
I want to deeply embed  that
into my product.
I hit save in the library and
switch over to my design file,
sketch pops this little purple
bar in the corner letting me
know  the underlying library has
been updated.  If I click on
this,  it's going to give me a
-- these are all the components
that are  going to be affected
by these changes.  I can choose
whether to  select them or not.
I'm going to take all these
changes.
So now any component which is
aware of the shape system is
going to be updated.
So if I zoom in on this bottom
sheet here, for example, you
can see it picked up on that cut
corner.  Likewise, on this
raise button down here, it's
shaped.
Some of the components in the
system
offer a different  variance
which can or cannot pick up on
the parameter system.
For example, here is a fab using
the standard circular
presentation.
If I go into the symbol settings
I can select a different
alternative, if I want it to be
aware of the pattern or not.
I can pick up on the diamond
shapes, or the circular, if I
want to.
Seeking of variations, we
introduced variance on text
fields  which seem to be
performing really well.
So I can go into my design and
select the underlying text
field and switch it
out to a different variant from
those  available in my sticky
sheet.
So we have a different variance
using this outline which is
much more unobvious.
The next parameter I want to
look at is typography.
Currently the I/O app is using
Google Sans which is their
brand type face.
I think we may be able to take
inspiration from a developer
event and
take inspiration from developer
environments and try a
mono-space font and see how it
works.
If I go to the typography
settings from
the theme editor, it  has a
scale here
that's been generated for me
giving me semantic  stars I can
apply throughout my design.
If I search for mono-space, I'm
going to use Robotow one of  my
favorites.
It's going to swap that out
everywhere the font  was used.
I can go in and manually change
it, also.
It's going to do something
interesting.
While it's set to Google Sans,
it had a particular weight  and
font.
When I switched it, the font
size, tracking, and  weight,
changed as well.
So this looks at the font's
characteristics and corrects for
them to create an harmonious
scale.
That means if your font you're
choosing
as a different X  height or
something
like that, it will adjust for
that, for the  different types
of scale, to
produce this harmonious scale
for  you.
By selecting this font, it
selecting the scale for me,
which  is pretty amazing.
Again, this notifies me the
library has been updated.  I can
take all those changes.
Everywhere I was using the other
font  family before in my
design, you can see
it's been updated to my  new
typeface.
(Applause)
Go theme editor.
So these changes are looking
pretty good to me.  I want to
share them with the rest of the
team.
You cannot only get really tight
integration with theme  editor
but also
with Gallery.
I can set the product or
subcollection in which to put
this  and upload it straight
away.
So once that's uploaded, it's
ready to
be share we'd the  shared with
the
team, so I get a unique URL I
can share with the team.
So in Gallery I get an overview
of my
design work and update  new
iterations.  I can see how it
evolved and I can comment and
have a discussion about
different design features.
I want to show you a favorite
feature which is in spec mode.
This makes it easy to hand off
to developers and for
developers to get all the
information we need out of a
design.
I get this inspection on the
right.
When I hover over any  item, it
will
red-line it for me
automatically, gives me size,
position information, and
gives me the copy and all the
typeface  information.
And it will also pick up on any
icons
you use from the  material
theme, any material icons will
link out to the material  site.
You can grab whatever you need,
straight away from there.
Best of all, Gallery understands
the components that the  theme
editor creates.
If I select this fab here, it's
not
just  going to say, hey, this is
a blue circle.  It's going to
say,  hey, I recognize that's a
fab.
You can see it picks up it's a
Best of all, it offers  per
platform reference to
documentation so developers can
go  directly to the component
they
need to implement and they'll be
given any parameter changes
you've changed on the component,
as  well.
I can't emphasize this enough.
You're no longer handing over  a
picture and saying, hey, I
really hope you can implement
this.   Between theme editor and
Material design components,
they're the  same components.
Which means you're saying use
this component  with these
parameter changes to it.
No longer is it a guessing
game.
So these changes look good to
me.
I'm going to open up the
comment
feature and at Will and let him
know
these changes have  been
uploaded to Gallery and ready
for implementation.  Over to
you, Will.
>> WILL LARCHE: Thanks, Nick.
Isn't it great?
(Applause)
So I'm an engineer and Nick has
just shared with me this
gallery project.  I got the
link.
I click on it and I get to  come
in
here and it will send me to the
Material components
documentation.
Now, what is Material
components?
Material components are an
open-source
framework for  implementing
Material Design.
It's the same code Google uses
in its apps.
Each has dozens of components,
and they can all do the cool
things Nick was talking about
earlier.
And since they're open-source
there's no mystery.  They're
not magic boxes.  Everything is
available to you to look at or
customize.
And we invite you to please
contribute code.
So let's look at these new text
fields in Material  components.
How do I get them?
Adding MDC to your code base is
pretty  easy.
If you're on Android you'll
access the design support
library  through maven
using the standard support
library setup.
On Web you install a node
module.
On Flutter, you're done.
Material components come built
into  flutter.
On iOS, you can use CoCo pods.
Every text field has two parts:
An input and controller.
We're going to add MDC text
field and controller to our app.
We can lay it out using
intrinsic content size.
And maybe set the UI text field
delegate.
And the place holder will float
across the border.
If you're already using MDC,
upgrading is pretty easy to get
these new designs.
If you're using CoCo pods you
just run pod update material
components.
Then you change from the old
class to
one of the new fancy  ones, like
Outlined, and you're done.
By the way, these text fields
are much better and much more
performance than the previous
designs.
We did a huge amount of research
in order to come up with  these
optimized designs.  A lot of
research.  (Laughter)
And it turns out that in long
form, your users are much more
likely to see and interact with
these text fields than the
previous design.
If you want to learn more about
the new text fields or  material
research, you
can watch the talk "measuring
material"  Thursday at 12:30.
So doing this on iOS is a
breeze.  What about Android?
Well,  you set the outline box
style in our layout.
On Web you replace an element
with class MDC line ripple with
an element with
class MDC notched outline, with
an SBG
with a  path of class MDC...
and don't forgot the modifier
class MDX
outlines (speaking quickly
purposefully).  It couldn't be
simpler!
Now, I'm a little bias because I
work on MDC Flutter, but I
think Flutter is the
perfect way to implement
Material Design  across
platforms.  You do it once and
you get both iOS and  Android.
And MDC is baked right in.
It is the default framework for
Flutter.  Whenever you create  a
new project, it's already
linked.  I love it!
So now you know that the
material text fields can be
added to  your code, but there's
a lot more.
You can find almost all of the
Material guidelines components
in Material components.
That's buttons, carts, chips,
dialogues, navigation tabs, ink
ripples, there are dozens of
them now.
They're all available to you now
at material material.io/develop.
Since design is never done, more
are added all the time.
So today, we've shown you the
design
resources available to  you
today on material.
io, how theme editor, gallery,
and the
material tools suite help you
customize your designs for your
brand, and how material
components make it easy to
implement  those designs across
four
platforms, with precision and
ease.
What else can you do?  Go to our
design dome where you can  get
design reviews and demos and
listen to your box talks.
And  you can also go see the
talk Code
Beautiful UI with Flutter and
Material Design.
And on Wednesday at 2:30 there's
a
session:
Ask Flutter,  where you can come
to us
and ask how you can implement
Material  Design into your
Flutter apps.
Thank you.
(Applause)
>> WILL LARCHE: All right.
(End session
at
5:28 p.m.
PT.)
(Music)
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 08, 2018
STAGE 4
6:00 P.M.
PT
NEW AND ADVANCED GOOGLE PLAY
TOOLS FOR
GAME DEVELOPERS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
* * *
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of proceedings. This
text, document, or file is not
to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
* * *
(Music)
>> Hi.
I'm Jonathan Cheung
, tech lead of the Google Play
Console.
And I'm here with Ignacio and
David.
We're excited to  talk to you
about what Play console tools
you can take advantage  of in
building and managing your
games.
Fact, in the last few  years,
the number of Android players
who have installed the game  has
more than doubled.
Players from all around the
world and  all different
backgrounds are enjoying an
unprecedented amount  of new
game play experiences of
Android.
As game developers, this is your
chance.
Your chance to  build new
experiences, to connect to more
players, and to find  success in
the market.
Whether you're a new developer
building
your first game or  seasoned
veteran of the industry, the
opportunity is yours to  grasp.
That being said, with
opportunity comes
a degree of risk.   Games
development on mobile is an
ever-changing landscape and
player expectations for mobile
games has never been higher.
There's more competition than
ever before in the marketplace.
There are already 1 million
games live
on the Play Store and  new games
are launching all the time on
Google Play.
Development costs are increasing
due to
the demands of higher  fidelity
on mobile games, and consumers
are
expecting more  feature-rich
experiences on mobile.
Finally, marketing games is
getting increasingly more
difficult.  User acquisition
spending is
increasing as  developers are
more towards fewer larger
launches in a single  year.
As Google Play, we understand
these problems and want to help
you where we can to bring as
much success as possible to your
games.
We are committed to building
tools to help you plan and
de-risk your launches, and to
help you maintain and
support your  games after
successful launch.
Let us take you on a journey
from pre- to post-launch which
will hopefully provide insights
into some of the exciting tools
we have available for you.
We will be covering some
existing tools,
share some  interesting
anecdotes and best practices,
and show off some new  tools
which we feel will help you on
your road to success.
First, prelaunch.
This phase is critical for
delivering to  your players,
whether that be the game
experience yourself, the
stability and performance of
your game, or in the content
road  map you have planned.
We're going to be going through
some areas of focus during
prelaunch and also walk through
some of these tools we feel are
helpful at this stage.
First, and perhaps the most
importantly, testing.  It is
crucial to get your testing
strategy right when launching a
new  game.
As you know, launching and
maintaining games is an
expensive proposition.
It is critical to make sure that
when
you launch your product  it will
be
stable and bug-free,
resonate with your players from
a game
play perspective, and have a
sustainable road map to keep
players invested in your game.
Internal testing allows you to
publish
your APK in seconds  instead of
hours.
It also features integrations of
our
API and  other third-party
plug-ins.
Finally, it benefits from all
the Google
Play products you've  come to
love, such as in-app product
support, country targeting,
LDL, and of course the newly
announced Android app bundle.
Developers are using this new
track to
do rapid iterative  testing, for
launching new games as well as
adding features to  existing
games.
For instance, using it to push
daily builds to QA in order to
make sure
releases
meets their quality, or using it
for  experimental builds for
friends and
colleagues
in order to play  test new
mechanics.
Here is something to think
about.  It's great to focus on
stability and
bugs, in order to judge every
release against your  bar for
quality.
It can also be useful to start
testing
on a wide variety of  devices,
so when
you decide to roll out to more
players, you can  be certain
they receive the quality game
play experience you  would want
them to receive.
One of our most used feature for
game developers is closed
testing.
Closed testing is a great
opportunity
to build a  tight-knit
opportunity of testers who can
provide you valuable
feedback before and after
launch.
Users can be invited directly
from the
Play console using  email lists
or Google groups.
They can then opt in via web app
as shown in this picture.
Once opted in they can install
the game directly from the  Play
Store.
Over 60% of game developers on
Play
already use this feature  and
have found great success with
it.
Let's look at a case study.
Brav aco really took to heart
building a strong user comment
for their closed tests.
They focused on the recruiting
the right
sort of players,  reaching
beyond the usual communities, to
find the player they  felt would
be the theme of their game,
which is a military  shooter
game.
They went to this Air Soft event
and
recruited players  on-site to
play their game.
During the testing period,
Bravoco made
sure they were able  24/7.
They allowed them very specific
valuable feedback but  also to
build connections with
individual testers of their
game.
This dedication to building a
strong
test community paid off
dividends, both
during testing and even after
launch in
early  access where Forces of
Freedom has now attracted more
than  10 million players and
counting.
In conclusion, here are some
things to think about when using
closed testing.  Create a strong
and diverse test community.
Remember, these players will be
critical in shaping the initial
direction of your game.
Experiment with new game play
mechanics and content.  Don't
be afraid of negative feedback.
Remember, your ratings and
reviews are still not live at
this point.
And finally, think about
reaching out to
your testing  community to
gather very specific feedback.
This is your chance  to ask them
what
works, what didn't work, and how
do we improve.
Next, open testing.  Once a game
is technically solid and  your
main game play hooks are built
in, it's time to think about
expanding your test to more
players in preparation for your
big  launch.
Open testing allows your game to
be discoverable and  installable
on the
Play Store and for players, up
to a
developer  defined cap, to opt
in and install your game.
Players won't be able to leave
ratings
into it fully launches  but can
provide anonymous feedback to
the developer at any time.
Open testing comes in two
flavors depending on the state
of  your game.
If you don't have a production
release already,  you're in the
same country
you're running the test in,
users can  install your game
directly from the Play Store
without needing  to opt in.  We
call this "early access."
Your game will be tagged as
unreleased, as shown in this
image.
If you have a production release
already, for instance, you  may
have soft launched in the same
country, you can still  continue
to use open testing.  Existing
users will continue to  get
updates on the test track and
new users
can opt in via a  console
provided web link or a card
shown on the screen here,
at  the bottom of the game's
details page.
Players opted into an  open test
in this state will see the tags.
So bringing together these forms
of testing, internal test  and
closed test,
you as the developers have
control over who can  install
and play your game.
Early access tests can be
installed and discovered
directly  from the Play Store
and they're a great way to
expand your  tester base, as
well as building height around
your big launch.
Finally, open tests can be used
to continue testing with a  wide
audience even after your
production release.
Utilize these testers to try out
new features and tweaks to  your
game before rolling out to all
your players.
Moving on, prelaunch reports can
also
help developers iron  out
quality and
performance issues prior to
launch.
Whenever  test ABK is uploaded a
non-deterministic bot will call
your name  while it's running on
a real physical device in one of
our test  labs.
Game developers have found a lot
of value in the prelaunch
report.  90% of developers don't
push to
production if the  report shows
issues.
Demo loops goes even further for
game developers.
Records  and upload the game
demo loop using 5 test lab and
receive a  report on craft and
performance metrics including
the all  important frames per
second.
This allows you to discover
rendering
issues even faster and  launch
with greater confidence.
The developers of titles such as
fruit ninja have found great
value in demo loops.
They've developed a process
around
demo  loops as it allows them to
check for visual glitches and
crashes  and performance and
many other things.
They rely on the fact that PLR
will automatically run on a
wide range of devices and device
specs for every test release.
How did they do this?
Their new game, Endless Runner
has a
built in replay functionality
used to record game runs.
They can instrument PLR game
loops to run on these recorded
sessions.  Whereas before, it
was a very manual process to
pick  up their benchmarking.
Now, with PLR demo loops, it's
automated  for them for every
test release.
They can look at these metrics
and compare them to every
previous release
to make sure their game has no
regressions in  terms of
performance.
Before we move on to launching,
another
important aspect of  prelaunch
is to plan your strategy around
content.
As such,  don't be afraid to
test longer and earlier.
Consider using longer-term
metrics like
D14 and D30 in order  to predict
future success.
Measure the rate of content
consumption during your testing
phase.  This can be useful for
planning ahead, so that you have
enough content for
your players when you launch
until your first  big update.
Also, this phase is a great
opportunity to test what sort of
live-up events will resonate
with your player base so that
you  can create the content that
your players will want to
receive.
It is also important to consider
how different forms of  testing
can be used
to achieve different purposes.
All testing tracks can be used
in unison with each other,
allowing you to target different
experiences to different groups
of testers.
For instance, you may want to
consider
to run your daily bill  past
your
internal test users to track for
regressions at the  same time
you're
running large open scale test
for open access.
Closed testing can also be used
for specific game play
mechanics to select
users before running out to
production  users.
Finally, you should always keep
in mind that mobile games
development is ever-changing
landscape.  New technologies are
opening up new
ways to play, and player
expectations of mobile  are
ever-changing.  Remember to
continue to evaluate your
processes around development and
testing, see what works, what
doesn't work, and most
importantly do not be afraid of
change.
With that, I would like to hand
over to Ignacio who is going  to
talk to you about launching
games on Google Play.
(Applause)
>> IGNACIO MONEREO: Thanks,
Jonathan.  Hi, everyone.
I'm  Ignacio, part of the Play
team based in London.  I have
the  privilege and honor to work
with many game developers like
you.   Let's talk about
launching your game.  I'm pretty
sure by now  you have tested and
tested your game.
And you are 100%  confident or
let's say at least 95% confident
that your game is  ready both
from the back end and front end
to receive a lot of  users, that
as well your customer teams are
ready to manage the  community,
create new live events, or deal
with the feedback,  but above
all that your game is lots of
fun.
And soAnd it's still scary,
right?
in the Play Console we hopefully
have
some tools to help you  reach
levels of confidence.
We'll talk about three in
particular.  Device catalog,
preregistration, and then last,
country targeting.
Let's look at them in further
detail.
So device catalog, this feature
is very popular.
And the  reason is because it
helps
you make better decisions when
getting back fixes and
delivering the right experience
for each  device.
Since launch last year we've
seen 66% of developers are using
it on a monthly basis.
We all know Android is
incredible with  hundreds of
manufacturers and thousands of
devices.  So let's  turn these
into an opportunity and try to
deliver the best  experience
based on relevant factors
such as SOC, RAM, or CPU.
But during this process, there's
one key thing to remember,
which is essentially to think
big.  What I mean by think big
is  just let's try to include as
many devices by default as
possible.
Excluding devices should be a
temporary measure until some of
these bugs are fixed.
Let's look at the device title
page.
The device detail page is a
feature that allows you to
review  individually
thousands of devices and
identify
relevant criteria  such as RAM,
CPU, so forth.
.
So we added things, such as the
unsupported reason, since  last
year, so you can very quickly
identify why a device isn't
supported by your game.
Lastly, I wanted to highlight
also some interesting
information that the device
detail page is dividing.
Essentially, the number of
active
devices in this particular
game, the
average rating, and the revenues
generated by either  purchases
or subscriptions in the last
month.
So what are some developers
saying about this?
So a mobile  developer from
Barcelona,
they launched a very popular
game:  Respondables, which
is launched in 2013, and since
then
they've  seen more than 2
billion battles played by the
players.
So they check the device catalog
two or three times a week.
They exclude those devices that
do not
meet the minimum  requirements
in order to deliver a great user
experience.
Second, they isolate the bugs.
Third, they prioritize device
support,
as well as these bug   fixes.
Thanks to this feature, they've
seen increase in user
experience, and ratings, as well
on the overall quality and
performance of the game.
So in conclusion, I wanted to
highlight three things to
remember.  So the first one:
Think big and support as many
devices as possible.
Second, if we have to exclude
some devices, try to do it in a
temporary way so we can fix all
those bugs and increase our
chances to reach a bigger
audience.
And then, last, use the device
detail page to get very
relevant information such as,
for example, the unsupported
reason, or their average
revenues or average rating.
And with this, let's move on to
the next
functionality  feature:
Preregistration.
We all know in gaming creating
excitement before launch is
increasing popular.
The preregistration has two
benefits.  As a player, it's
clear.  You can preregister and
then when the game is launched
you'll receive a notification to
install the game.  We all know
in certain types of games
-- multiplayer, competitive
games in  general -- it's
critical to have a very
early, or get on early  into the
game.
However, from a developer
perspective, I can see there's
two  main benefits here.  The
first one is you can start
marketing  early, and capture
the audience's interest.
As well, by  monitoring the
preregistration count we have an
indication of  the influx of
users at launch and we can plan
ahead not only  from a server
side but also, like, marketing.
Let's look another a case study.
Next one is a Korean  developer,
and
creator of Durango Wild lands
launched in  January 25, 2018 in
Korea.
They started preregistration six
weeks before launching the
game.  They saw 2.5 million
preregistration users.
Out of  those, 46% were coming
from the Play preregistration
feature.
What is very interesting here is
that
the day-seven  conversion,
meaning from launch date until
the day seven, the
first week, the conversion for
Play
preregistration users was  about
70%, which is seven times higher
than the other sources.
So they at platform relations
says it's
essentially a very  effective
marketing tool.
So Nexon has launched 20 games
in 2017 and has used the
preregistration feature in ten
games last year.
They saw a 50%  conversion from
preregistration users to actual
users  downloading this app,
this game.
They've seen also the CPI's are
quite lower.
They're 60%  lower in prelaunch
than postlaunch period.
As such, it led to a discussion
to
allocate marketing budget  50%
to the
prelaunch state rather than
postlaunch.
So far the preregistration pilot
has been very successful.   In
2017 we've seen numbers such as
more than 50 developers using
this functionality, as well as
200 million players registering
and a hundred million players
actually downloading
those games,  and a total of 400
launches across both small and
big  developers.
Indeed, this is exciting.
But what's even more exciting is
to know that today we're
announcing that
preregistration is  becoming
available to all developers very
soon.
So what are some of the things
we need to take into account  if
we want to have a good
experience with preregistration?
So three things, as well, that I
wanted to remember.
So the  first is allow some time
to build excitement.  So in
between  three to six weeks,
it's enough in order to gather
all this  audience interest.
As well, use all the channels
that you have available in
order to build that excitement.
For example, media communities,
forum, your own website.
Across all these channels, make
sure you have a clear action.
In this case, preregister Google
Play.
With this in mind, let's jump
into the
last tool, which is  country
targeting.
Country targeting is a very
powerful tool.
Essentially, it  allows two
things: Different tracks per
country and can run open  test
or production in a specific
geography.
This is very useful for
self-launching purposes where we
want  to have one particular
region in production to test
user  acquisition or
monetization.
Second is geography.  You can
control the roll-out in
different countries and then
monitor which users are getting
into the app.
This allows us to test
performance or user  feedback.
Let's look at how some
developers are using this
functionality.
War of Gaming, they launched
this game
in January, 2018, and  the game
has already seen more than 3
million installs in Google
Play.
By the way, a hundred million
sheeps
destroyed and more than  50
million
planes shot down.  Incredible
numbers on that side.
We spoke with the marketing
manager in war gaming and he
told  us they use the country
targeting during the soft launch
period.
This soft launch period took
about six
months and they  divided in
three stages.  The first stage
they select a few  number of
countries and were testing
things like stability, so  crash
rates,
monetization, and then
engagement, user engagement  and
duration of the games.
On the second stage they open up
to a few more countries and
they were
testing mostly server capacity
and ensuring the  stability of
the game.
On a third stage they were
opening up to already more
countries across all
continents, with an interest of
testing  monetization mostly.
So lastly, during this whole
process, war gaming was testing,
as well, and
monitoring the ratings and
reviews and reacting  based on
the user feedback.
In conclusion, regarding country
target, two things to  remember
today.  The first one is we can
use country
targeting  during soft launch
but also
during the open and close beta
test
processes, as well as during
future
updates or postlaunch  period.
The second thing, at launch,
plan ahead what is going to be
the roll-out to the different
countries.  So people can
download  the game and enjoy it
quickly without any issues.
With this, I would like to call
my colleague, David.  Thank
you.
(Applause)
>> DAVID WIESENFELD: Thanks,
Ignacio.  I'm David.
Product  manage on Play console
market
tools and Google Play game
services of.
Now we're moving on to post
launch.  At this point you
developed your
game, tested with a growing
cohort of
testingers,  add a good launch
day and launch week and the dust
is settling.
what do you think about next?
Three post launch activities
we'll focus on are growing your
audience to get as many people
as possible playing your
great  game, engaging your
players to a great experience
they can keep  coming back to,
and earning money so you can
keep growing your  game or build
your next one.
Let's start with audience
growth.
Players with becoming harder and
more expensive to acquire  and
retain.  Game developers like
you are using
lots of  different strategies to
acquire users.
UA is common but so are other
less trackable methods.
Cross  promotion and other
games,
utilizing social channel
s,  third-party marketing, and
others as well.
Players who install your app
organically from the Play Store
who may get there from a search
after reading about your game
from a third-party website are a
black box.
Using new tools in Play Console
you can
now see the breakdown  of how
many new installers are accessed
your listing
either by a  search or by
browsing the Play Store.
Most users find games using
search.  You can see the
specific  search terms that
drive users to your game.
Organ acquisitions insight
reports is coming soon to all
developers.
The developer we've talked to
are
excited to use these  insights
in order to access strategies,
change their screenshot  to
reflect what their users
are looking for, and even
optimize  app experiences to
make sure it references the
features that  users find more
appealing.
This is a powerful new tool I
hope you'll explore.
You can go together talk
tomorrow morning to find out
more  about it.
Next, we'll talk about Google
Play instant.
Growing your game is getting
users excited about it.  A great
way to do that is to get them
excited by using and
experiencing  it.
We launched this last year and
since
then we've been very   busy.
We've made building in snaps
even easyier.
As of today, Google Play instant
is now
available to all game
developers.
So why should you consider
making an instant game?
Instant games allow players to
try your
game before  installing it and
make it easy to install the full
game at the
end of the instant game
experience using the install
prompt API.
Being able to try a game before
installing is a hit with
players.
After publishing their instant
game
Mighty Battles saw  a 19%
increase in acquisition rate.
So what's the difference between
instant apps and instant  games?
We adapted the instant app
framework so it better meets
the needs of game developers
like you.
There's three things we changed.
We increased the size limit  to
10-megabyte.
We enabled progressive
download...and very
importantly, we've added full
support for native code and are
we  go
grading with game engines and
open PL.
And by creating an instant game
you open up a lot of  surfaces.
Players can experience instant
games
directly from
ads, in the play game
arcade, via a messaging app, and
of course  in the Play Store.
We need to touch back just for a
moment on launching tools.
Preregistration is a very
successful program.
We're bringing  the instant
games to Play Store's
preregistration feature.
Now  players that preregister
did get a sneak preview of your
game.
And users will be able to play
instantly
from any Android  device when
you promote it on social media.
It's an awesome way  to
introduce your game to the
world.
To learn more about instant
games, you can attend this
session on Thursday.
Next, we'll look at engagement.
Android vitals is designed to
help you identify issues at
scale so you can
create a better, more fluid,
more optimized and  more
engaging experience for your
players.
There are a number of new vitals
features launching including
benchmarks for vitals and new
vitals including startup time
which we discussed in the
Android vitals session earlier
this  afternoon.
Of particular and of game
developers are stability and
battery statistics.
We are now showing these vitals
against
a bad behavior  threshold.
Exhibiting bad behavior and
vitals will negatively  infect
the user experience in your game
and can result in bad  ratings
and poor discoverability in the
Play Store.
We also have renders for
start-up time but that's
informable  at this point.
You can can see how you stack up
against
similar games with  these
benchmarks.
Using vitals, game developer
Kaloo who game subway surfers
was able to make distract
improvements to their A and R
rate,  reducing it to below 0.
1%.
So help you ensure your users
enjoy playing your game, you
should be thinking about using
vitals in your day-to-day.
Keep  an eye on A and Rs,
crashes,
wake locks and wake ups, which
will  be
easier with alerts build in.
And use your tool kit to chase
down problems.
We wanted to share with you
something we've been working on.
It's not ready for general
consumption yet.  That's coming.
But  we're excited to be working
to bring live ops to play.
We're  creating new experiences
in the
store and in the Play games app
to show players events that are
happening now in their games.
This is proving very popular
with players and we'll continue
exploring in this direction.
Finally, let's move on to
revenue.
Google Play has had
subscriptions since 2012.
Games  typically monetize
through...
but a number have been
experimenting with subscriptions
and we wanted to share their
experiences.
What's the benefit of adding
subscriptions when I already
have IAP?
There's an increase in
engagement and
retention not  just for
subscribers but overall user
base, as well.
Many also notice minimal canal
billization.
Another developer who has found
success
with subscriptions is  Network
in Legendary Game of Heroes.
They use subscriptions for
their loyalty VIP program.
This has proven popular with
players, as you can see, and
created a new revenue stream for
them with strong
overall impact on overall
revenue.
There are two ways to use
subscriptions.  Loyalty programs
for high value users
and a new access point for a
premium
experience to nontraditional
buyers.
Some examples of a VIP loyalty
feature includes exclusive or
early access to content, special
VIP status and title, or a
bonus payout with each purchase.
This is the most popular
subscription design we've seen
so  far.
As you can see from Jurassic
world the game, here.
Developers have also found
subscriptions can be effective
in  converting traditional
non-buyers.
These players are motivated by
getting a good financial deal.
You can see this program aimed
at these traditional
non-buyers.
As with any monetization system,
be aware of potential down
sides and keep a close pulse of
player feedback and community
sentiment.
To help you with your
subscription
program, Google Play has a  very
robust subscriptions
infrastructure with a lot of
rich  features.
We support you with building
tools and
analytics  insights reports
through the
entire tunnel and we can take
care  of
features such as flexible
billing, free
trials, account hold,  so you
can test this in in-game
subscription design.
To learn more, you can watch the
recording of this session  from
earlier this afternoon.
We've gone through some of the
tools you
can take advantage  of post
launch but as we draw to a close
I want to loop us back  to the
beginning of our talk and call
out testing again.
In comparison to apps, this can
be tricky for games as some
games need people to be on the
same version to function
possibly.  But think about how
you can use testing tracks to
ensure your updates
live up to the quality bar set
for your  game.
To wrap up, we discussed a
number of tools in Play Console
you can use in
various stages in your game's
life cycle.   There's a lot
going on in mobile gaming right
now.
Fantastic  game growth, and lots
of
competition, it's your own fault
as you  keep raising the bar
higher and higher in terms of
graphics,  story, and game play.
We're excited to see what you're
going
to build next and  where games
goes on from here.
We can help you along in a few
key places and give you
abilities and insights you can
leverage to help you succeed.
We'd also love to hear your
feedback on this session.
Thanks for your time.  We're
around for the rest of the day.
You can also check out the
sandbox over here.  Thank you.
(Applause)
(Music)
(End session at 6:37 p.m. PT.)